what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be talking about a
thought that i had
um for the young girls i don't think
there's a lot of young girls that watch
me before the ones that do
um this is a message for you because
this is what i wish i knew
when i was younger about like dating and
guys um
number one you don't have a guy that's
just like out there
waiting for you you have to earn and you
have to deserve a husband i think
because like most of our parents like
got married or
um ended up like married to someone
growing up everyone just assumed like
they would get married and you have a
husband waiting out there for you but
the thing is you choose who you date so
you are a hundred percent
in control of who your husband is going
to be
so one choose wisely and two
you really do reap what you sow if
you're putting
your like body out there on all of your
social medias if that's the image
that you're portraying of yourself
that's the type of husband you're gonna
get
so like don't be surprised if your
boyfriend
is liking uh
other girls on instagram if the reason
you got him
is because you put your body out there
and that's how you caught them
i don't know if that makes sense but
yeah i i don't believe that you just
have like this one person you're
supposed to be with i genuinely believe
like
you reap what you sow and if you
present yourself a certain way on social
media if you act a certain way
you're gonna you're gonna a lot of guys
aren't gonna wanna date you because you
do that
so just like my two cents i would really
be cautious about what you put
on the internet because that's going to
be on there forever and i wouldn't put
anything
on the internet um that you wouldn't
want your future husband or your kids to
see
so speaking from experience okay
speaking from experience